lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
demostrar que la derivada con respecto a
x el logaritmo natural de x es 1 / x
empecemos vamos a usar la definición de
derivada es decir la derivada con
respecto a x el logaritmo natural de x
es igual a el límite cuanto delta de x
tiende a cero de el logaritmo natural de
x más delta de x - el logaritmo natural
de x entre delta de x
así que ahora podemos utilizar algunas
propiedades de los logaritmos para
trabajar esta expresión porque sabemos
que el logaritmo natural de amp menos el
logaritmo natural de bem hecho es igual
a logaritmo natural de a entrever por lo
tanto podemos usar esto de aquí porque
tenemos el logaritmo natural de algo
menos el logaritmo natural de otra cosa
por lo que todo esto va a ser igual a el
límite cuando delta de x tiende a cero
del logaritmo natural de eb y observa
aquí tengo la diferencia de dos
logaritmos por lo tanto me va a quedar
el logaritmo natural de x + delta de x /
x ok esto adentro del logaritmo y es el
logaritmo dividido entre delta de x una
vez más si tengo el logaritmo natural de
una expresión menos el logaritmo natural
de una segunda expresión eso es lo mismo
que el lugar natural de la primera
expresión entre la segunda expresión
esto viene de las propiedades de los
logaritmos
dentro de este paréntesis esto es lo
mismo que dividir todo entre equis y me
quedaría uno más delta de equis entre
equis de modo que si ahora escribo esto
de esa manera
observa voy a poner el límite cuando
delta se extiende a cero de iu primero
voy a poner uno entre delta de x que es
lo mismo que dividir entre delta de x
esto que multiplica al logaritmo natural
y ahora sí voy a dividir tú entre x y me
quedaría 1 + delta de x / x y bueno
estoy escribiendo 1 entre delta de x
primero porque ahora podemos usar otra
propiedad de los logaritmos que dicen
que si tengo a por el logaritmo natural
de b
eso es el logaritmo natural de b elevado
a la así que en este caso nuestra am va
a ser 1 entre delta de x y voy a traerla
y ponerla como exponente y todo esto me
va a quedar como el límite cuando delta
de x tiende a cero
de el logaritmo natural de uno más delta
de x entre x ok elevado a la 1 entre
delta de x y estoy seguro que esto te
empieza a parecer bastante familiar
porque esto es muy parecido a nuestra
definición de y de hecho estamos muy
cerca de esa definición y para que
claramente se vea lo que voy a hacer es
un cambio de variable voy a decir sea n
igual a delta de x / x en este caso y
ahora si multiplicas ambos lados por x
entonces obtienes que delta de x era lo
mismo que n por x sólo estoy
multiplicando de ambos lados de la
ecuación por x y cambiando los lados y
por lo tanto si queremos saber cuánto es
uno entre delta de x bueno 1 entre delta
de x es igual a 1 entre nx que no
podemos escribir como 1 entre n por uno
entre x
así que estas dos son nuestras
sustituciones que voy a hacer y sólo
falta saber a qué se aproxima n decir
mirad si delta de x tiende a 0 entonces
n tiende bueno veamos si delta de x
tiende a cero entonces n va a ser igual
a delta de x / x y por lo tanto también
se aproxima a cero y esto está bien
porque observa pero no está en el
dominio del hogar ido natural de x
entonces ahora sí si delta de x tiende a
cero
entonces n tiende a cero y también
puedes pensarlo en el sentido contrario
si n tiende a cero
entonces delta de x tiende a cero bien
ahora hagamos nuestro cambio de variable
si hacemos las sustituciones adecuadas
en lugar de tomar el límite cuando delta
se extiende a 0 ahora voy a tomar el
límite cuando n tiende a 0 de que den el
logaritmo natural de uno más n elevado y
recuerda esto es lo que valían 1 entre
delta de x es 1 entrenen x 1 / x
entonces tenemos por aquí 1 entre delta
de equis y voy a poner uno entre n por
uno entre x entonces tengo esto elevado
a la 1 entre n por 1 entre x y ahora
podemos aplicar esta propiedad de los
logaritmos de nuevo pero en esta ocasión
a la inversa
de hecho déjame antes de escribir esto
de otra forma observa esto es lo mismo
que el límite cuando n tiende a 0 de el
logaritmo natural de uno más en el
elevado a la 1 entre n
y ahora me falta este 1 / x pero si
tengo algo elevado a la multiplicación
de dos exponentes eso es lo mismo que
tomarme esta expresión elevada al primer
exponente y esto elevado el segundo
exponente y ahora podemos usar esta
propiedad de los logaritmos que te
decían de nuevo pero a la inversa con
esto voy a poder traer este 1 entre x al
frente y de hecho observar podemos
sacarlo completamente del límite así que
podemos sacarlo hasta acá y es que aquí
es donde empezamos a emocionarnos porque
observa esto va a ser igual a 1 entre x
por el límite cuando n tiende a 0 de el
logaritmo natural de uno más en el
elevado a la 1 entre n
ahora lo que realmente afecta al límite
es lo que pasa dentro del logaritmo
natural
allí es donde están todas las en es así
que podemos pensar en el límite dentro
del hogar es natural y entonces todo
esto será igual a bueno va a ser igual a
1 entre x por el logaritmo natural de el
límite cuando n tiende a 0 de 1 n
elevado a la 1 entre n observa el
logaritmo natural del límite cuando n
tiende a 0 elevado a la 1 entre n y es
que esto es bastante emocionante porque
que tenemos dentro del logaritmo natural
bueno todo esto que estoy poniendo a
blanco es la definición del número y así
que esto de aquí es igual a y ahora
cuántos el logaritmo natural de bueno es
simplemente 1
de manera que tengo 1 / x x 1 lo cual es
1 / x que es exactamente el resultado
que buscábamos está acá arriba que la
derivada con respecto a x del logaritmo
natural de x es 1 / x y entonces lo
hemos logrado así que nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo